Hello and welcome to Course 119.01 Introduction to Procedural Content Generation.
And this course and all of the included project files are going to be based in Unreal Engine
version 5.6. So what are our goals for this course? At the end of this, what we would like
you to do is have a good understanding of how the PCG or procedurally generated content
system within Unreal works. And so you've got a good foundation for creating your own
but your own procedural laid out levels. So for that, we hope that you understand
the concept of programming in a procedural manner. It's slightly different to the standard sequential
programming that most people think of where a lot of stuff is going to be happening at the same
time. We're going to be working with things called points a lot. Now what we're going to
do is we're going to do a reasonably long exercise where we're going to populate an
environment based on a PCG logic. Then what we're going to do is we're going to add a spline in,
and that's going to allow us some level of control over how we want things laid out,
but having everything populated around it automatically. Finally, we hope you get a good
idea of the limitations of the PCG system. And so you've got a good idea where you can use it
and where it's probably not appropriate. Now, in order to use the procedural content generation,
we're going to need one plugin, really, and that is the procedural content generation
framework. Now, if you don't have this switched on within the plugin settings,
you're not going to see any of the classes or the graphs, so you're not going to be able
to use it at all. On the project that we've provided, it's automatically turned on,
so you don't need to turn it on. Just be aware of it for future projects.
We are also turning on one more plugin, and that's the procedural content generation framework
geometry script interrupts. Now, this is not essential, but what it allows us to do
is it allows the PCG graphs to communicate with our geometry scripting system, which is
a bunch of functions and tools which will allow us to edit, manipulate, and
create meshes within the engine. So it is useful as a go-between between these two systems.
Before we start, I'd like to talk about two different concepts, which are sort of
important as we're going forward. And these two concepts are points and point density.
Now, when we're working with the PCG, we start off first by sampling the world. We can be looking
at the world around us, and off the back of that, we are going to be generating a number of
different points. Then a lot of the work that we're going to be doing is going to be about
manipulating these points, changing their size, space, filtering out some, moving some around.
And then finally, we're going to do something with these points.
In this example, we're mostly going to be creating a static mesh instance, which are
optimized versions of static meshes so that they can sort of appear in the world and not weigh
down the system too much. So 90% of the time, what we're going to be doing is we're going to
be changing the data on points based on some kind of logic. Now, all of these points can
contain something that's called attributes. And so attributes are just data which is on the points.
And these data can be anything for the obvious that's the transform of the point, so where it
is in space, location, rotation, and scale. But then it can be other elements, things like
its color, density, steepness, and we can also find a lot of user-specific attributes.
So it's important to understand that we have points and that attached to these points are
a number of different attributes that we are going to be playing around with or using.
And then at the end, we use the final points in order to
spawn and create things within the world. But we have points. And as you can see here,
you can see these cubes on the image that we have in front of us.
These are visual representations of the points that we have. So that's useful.
Now, the second point that I want to get across is point density. Now, if you look at all the
little cubes that we have in the world, they all have a different shade of gray going from
white to black. This is a visual representation of the value of point density. Now, what point
density is is this is going to be a value that we can use to do things like filter.
But by passing it in and out of the point density value, so for example,
we will pass the steepness of the points into it. By passing a value into it, we're going
to be able to visually see it on the debug screen here. So we'll have a good idea of what
it will look like. Secondly, we're going to be able to pass it into other nodes.
So we've got a lot of nodes that work with density to allow us to do things like filter.
So this is a value which we're going to be passing into the point density on specific points.
We're then going to be able to see what it looks like. And we're then going to be able to
use that in future calculations. So it's just a catch-all attribute we'll be passing values
in and out of. So next up, if you fire up a project, you should see something that looks
a little bit like this. Now, we have a specific little node that hopefully will pop up when the
project loads up. Now, what this is going to allow us to do is this is going to allow us to
move through the project, and it's going to help us to move to the correct
nodes that we have, the correct assets that we have inside the asset browser.
So for example, here, if I push to the beginning, it's going to take us back
to this beginning point here. Now, what I usually do with this is I'll drag this up
and drop it at the top here and move up the thing. So we can just see the top of it.
And we've still got a vision of the World Outliner. And it will allow us to move
back and forth through the project as we are working. The other thing that's worth noting
is we have a finished directory. Within that finished directory, you're going to find that
we have the finished assets that you are at any point you can come in and just have a look at.
So if you get stuck, you can come in and look at what we're ultimately building up.
And it's commented, we should have a good idea of what we're working with.
Okay. So if you got stuck in the finished directory, you should be able to find a
finished version of the exercise. Okay. So that should be everything for the first video.
Now we'll be able to jump into the project and start on the first exercise,
where we will be using a PCG to create a forest and then playing around with editing it.
So thanks a lot. I'll catch you in the next video.